وكيل الامين العام للامم المتحده للشؤون
الانسانيه مارتن ريفيث قد اقر بان المجتمع
الدولي خذل من يعيشون في شمال غربي سوريا
وقال انهم محقون في شعورهم بان المجتمع
الدولي تخلى عنهم بعد كارثه الزلزال وفي
كلمه من امام معبر باب الهوى بين تركيا
وسوريا قال غرفث ان الامم المتحده كثفت من
ادخال المساعدات عبر المعبر لتوفير
الاحتياجات الانسانيه العاجله لمنكوبي
الزلزال في شمال غربي سوريا
انا هنا في معبر باب الهوى بين تركيا من
خلفنا وشمال غرب سوريا وما نراه هنا هو
قافله مساعدات انسانيه لدينا قرابه 10
شاحنات ضمن هذه القافله لتوفير الاحتياجات
الانسانيه العاجله للاشخاص في شمال غرب
سوريا الذين يحتاجون اكثر من اربعه ملايين
منهم الى مساعدتنا والذين شكل الزلزال
بنسبه لهم تجربه مدمره هذه الشاحنات تمثل
شريان الحياه لقد استانفنا العمليات هنا
في الايام الاربعه او الخمسه الماضيه
وقمنا بتكثيف حشمها حتى نتمكن من البدء في
تلبيه احتياجات هؤلاء الاشخاص سنقوم
بتوجيه نداء لمرحله انسانيه مدهها ثلاثه
اشهر للاستجابه لتداعيات الزلزال سنقوم
بذلك خلال اليوم او اليومين المقبلين